[Music]
having enough money for retirement is a
concern for just about everyone and that
includes so-called Generation Xers
Americans born between the mid 60s and
the mid-90s won't start hitting
retirement age for another 12 years but
a new report by TD Ameritrade says many
believe they're not on track
37% say they'd like to fully retire but
don't think they'll be able to afford it
43 percent say they're behind in their
savings and 49 percent say they're
worried about running out of money once
they do leave the workforce here to
discuss the concerns is CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger Jill
good morning good morning
why are those Gen Xers so far behind
well there's a few things the older
Jennings's ready graduated into the 1987
stock market crash a quick recession
they bounced back pretty quickly but for
the middle to the younger part of this
generation just remember what happened a
dot-com boom and bust then a housing and
credit boom and bust the Great Recession
think about how many of these people
even if they were on track for
retirement previously had to then invade
their retirement accounts just to make
do this is a case of really bad timing
and it stinks because it's hard to
really struggle against that but there
are ways to move forward I did not
realize that Gen Xers carry more debt
than any other generation how and why is
that gel well I think part of the reason
is that again because of their ages they
have a lot of struggles so it's their
kids their aging parents this is a
Sandwich Generation their own student
loan debts they're juggling quite a bit
and when the bad times hit they had to
turn to quick and easy credit I'm not
saying that's a good thing you know I'm
going to put my certified financial
planner hat on no that's not a good
thing but we understand how it was
accumulated because there were a lot of
things coming at this generation at
different times in their lives
you mentioned the kids and the aging
parents the Sandwich Generation that
term I didn't know Jill how does that
affect planning well it's very hard you
know when you talk to financial planners
what they'll say is for a long
it was everybody was focused on how do I
get my kids through school how do I get
myself in retirement now our parents are
living longer so what we have to do is
as we start the planning process and
that's important we not only look at our
own kids ourselves and our parents but
there's a real there's a real point here
where you've got to put yourself first
right you remember when you go to the
airport and they go through your
security and you get on the plane they
say put that oxygen mask on yourself so
- with your financial planning you
really have to say look I know there's a
lot of things here but I've got to take
care of myself first I do have to help
my parents I'll do that with my family
I've got to help my kids but if I am NOT
secure in my own retirement and my
financial life is not secure everyone's
gonna have to take care of me eventually
how do you instill a sense of urgency in
a moment when you know retirement for
some people could be two or three
decades away yeah this is a struggle but
you know think about this one way I used
to do this when I was an adviser is I
would say you spend more time planning
your upcoming vacation than your
retirement right and that's just fun
right that's a little fun so let's talk
about how we're gonna make this fun how
are we gonna get you where you need to
go how can you focus on this now the
good news is technology has really
started to shape the experience in a
different way there are a lot of
calculators out there the most important
thing is to do it and then you've got
basically the idea here is pay down your
debt right get that emergency reserve
fund I know you know my producer just
yelled at me because no one has six to
twelve months of their expenses in the
bank I know it's hard but it's
aspirational so pay the debt down get
the emergency reserve and start saving
for a retirement first two steps but the
easiest first two steps just to get on
the road to this what are they on
automate everything so if you've got
outstanding debt and we know this
generation has a lot of debt put in some
automatic payments all the time next
step automate your investing just a
little bit if it's your retirement
account at work auto enroll in a 401 K
you don't even think about it as you're
not out of your hands it takes it's sort
of trumps all of your behavioral biases
so get the money out there your behavior
rolled by exactly stick to the plan and
more importantly have these
conversations with yourself if you need
help go get an advisor but again
so many resources online I really
encourage people to do it
automate automate automate now is the
time well it is January I'm still
thinking about that oxygen mask